[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a la histórica catedral de nôtre
dame en parís francia que hace dos años
fue noticia por el voraz incendio que
consumió gran parte de su estructura la
noche del 15 al 16 de abril de 2019 el
mundo presenció en vivo durante casi 15
horas a través de las pantallas como el
fuego que comenzó a bajo el techo del
edificio que se estaba restaurando se
fue extendiendo al marco y luego a la
aguja de 96 metros de altura el calor
derritió gran parte de los andamios
amenazando con derrumbar toda la
catedral después de una ardua noche de
lucha contra las llamas
los más de 600 bomberos movilizados
lograron salvar a notarán el daño es
gigantesco el edificio sigue en pie en
inmediato el gobierno francés empieza a
hablar de reconstrucción sin embargo
esta titánica labor no es fácil en medio
de la pandemia y el temor a la
contaminación por los residuos de plomo
del techo los periodistas estuvieron
junto a los hombres y mujeres que
trabajan en las obras de restauración el
calendario está apretado pues espera que
no traerán recupere su brillo en la
primavera de 2024 cuando parís sea la
sede
juegos olímpicos
[Música]
en el corazón de notredame a una herida
sigue abierta
una gran grieta donde se encontraba la
aguja de la catedral antes de
desplomarse 100 metros abajo el 15 de
abril de 2019 hubo caídas caídas de
materiales que cayeron al suelo aquí que
destruyeron casi por completo el suelo
del crucero y parte de la nave el suelo
de la nave y parte del suelo del coro
pascal brückner es uno de los
principales arquitectos encargados de la
restauración de notredame una catedral
medieval alta esbelta y también frágil
todo es delicado y los muros son
delgados las pilas son delgadas y es
como si se hubiera estirado el material
sin reforzarlo esos olores oa veces e
incluso muy a menudo llegamos a los
límites del material internamente
la parte más complicada está en la cima
de este bosque de andamios a casi 30
metros de altura
tenemos toda la vista del coro de esta
especie de catedral interior hecha de
andamios
y tú eres una hermosa vista una hermosa
arquitectura aunque sea algo temporal
mientras los trabajos de aseguramiento
se acercan a su fin
hay que reforzar urgentemente las
bóvedas del edificio una operación de
gran escala es inminente
[Música]
aquí se ven elementos que quedaron muy
deteriorados por el incendio estas
bóvedas son muy frágiles tienen entre 12
y 13 centímetros de grosor el fuego les
hizo perder probablemente a 2
centímetros los vitrales salvados por un
milagro están junto a los estigmas
piedras debilitadas marcadas por las
mangueras de los bomberos grietas que
datan de la edad media' reabiertas por
el calor extremo
y cuando decimos frágil podemos ver que
el triángulo que se vean desde la clave
está completamente gris por lo que las
piedras probablemente se cocieron y
tendremos que reemplazarlas estuvieron
sometidas a temperaturas de unos 800 900
grados
[Música]
el incendio que la razón notre damme
provocó una onda expansiva en la isla de
la city el barrio en el que fue
construida en el corazón de parís
[Música]
ah
puedo quedarme horas mirando en otra
edad
si tal yo es un lugar que desprende
mucha serenidad a pesar de todo lo que
ha pasado
durante los dos últimos años isabel ha
intentado hacer el duelo de su catedral
es difícil cuando todo le recuerda
aquella tarde del 15 de abril el post no
es sobre gabo w
creo recordar haber gritado cuando vimos
una llama entre las dos torres
absolutamente gigantesca que sobrepasaba
la cima de las torres naranjas esa vista
fue horrorosa europa les dice un lugar
[Música]
soy una de las cristianas y fieles de la
parroquia para nosotros no era un lugar
íntimo y de hecho nos llamaba era como
si nos trajera
ha visto un litro de aceite como vivo en
la isla del aceite empecé a ir a misa
como si fuera absolutamente imposible
resistirse a esa llamada además de los
fieles están los amantes del lugar y los
turistas de todo el mundo antes del
incendio 13 millones de personas pisado
en el suelo cada año convirtiendo a
notre damme en el monumento más visitado
de francia mucho antes de la pandemia de
kobe 19
los negocios del barrio ya se veían
afectados por su ausencia
farid o administra un restaurante en el
corazón del barrio
tristemente vacío desde hace dos años
recuerdas como era antes había mucha
gente era increíble
todos esos turistas que le dan vida a
parís que venían al otredad gracias a
ellos vive el distrito sí pero ahora que
no hay más turistas no hay nada y
claramente además tampoco vemos a los
locales no queda nadie creo que muchos
se fueron si ya no es como antes
es triste si es lamentable no puedo
esperar a volver a la vida de antes
exactamente
para devolver a la catedral su gloria de
antaño los artesanos trabajan duro en
toda francia a 300 kilómetros al este de
parís una empresa se esfuerza por
construir siembras gigantescas para
asegurar las bóvedas dañadas por el
fuego para combinar rapidez y precisión
en la obra se recurrió al modelado 3d se
trata de una medida de emergencia
los elementos deben fabricarse lo más
rápido posible si tuvieran que hacer sin
situ pasaríamos diez años allí o más
la última restauración de la catedral
medieval tuvo lugar en el siglo 19 y
duró dos décadas
no tenemos derecho a equivocarnos la
catedral está construida cuando se
construyó originalmente se trabajó con
formas perfectas en ese momento salvo
que con el tiempo el edificio se ha ido
más o menos deformando el incendio las
deformaciones que ha sufrido así que no
podemos volver a trabajar con formas
perfectas y por eso el modelado 3d es
algo de lo que no podemos prescindir hoy
en día los planos 3ds envían luego al
taller donde 52 medias perchas de madera
de abeto se construyeron a medida aquí
cada pieza es única y forma parte de un
enorme rompecabezas el producto de un
sutil equilibrio entre artesanía y
automatización esta es la pieza
terminada que se colocará bajo la bóveda
y por lo tanto permitirá aliviar la
piedra
es un brazo robótico que realmente
permite ajustarse a la curvatura puede
hacer cualquier forma esta tecnología la
que nos permite ir muy rápido la
tolerancia es milimétrica para nosotros
así que todo se hace con esa tolerancia
también es el director técnico del fg
la empresa ha restaurado los monumentos
son más emblemáticos de francia como el
louvre y versalles y el panteón el día
del incendio
la empresa estaba trabajando en la
estructura y la cubierta de notre-dame
para el equipo fue un doble gol de
presenciar el incendio a más de 300
kilómetros de distancia y estar en el
centro de la tormenta mediática
al principio no nos lo creíamos nos
decíamos que notre damme estaba en
llamas no entendíamos muy bien la
situación estábamos lejos veamos el
fuego extenderse por todas partes vimos
la aguja caer no nos sentíamos bien
francamente no lo creíamos y nos
quedamos toda la noche delante del
televisor estamos aquí para hacer
estructuras bonitas y de buena calidad
sigue las reglas del oficio y todo esto
se nos vino encima rumores falsos
rumores la gente casi que estaba
diciendo que nosotros éramos los
responsables del accidente
todo eso es mucho a la vez
desde entonces la empresa pudo presentar
una demanda civil y ahora mira hacia el
futuro
hacen todo lo posible para conservar lo
que se puede conservar del edificio
después de la conmoción es momento de
actuar
[Música]
el objetivo principal es salvar a notre
damme y notre damme es mundial
es un orgullo somos una pequeña de
numeración somos fuertes tenemos las
raíces de la clase trabajadora
las raíces agrícolas así que sabemos
cómo salir adelante y vamos a salir
adelante lo primero es asegurar la hora
mientras esperamos la reconstrucción
mucho podemos hacerlo
dentro de unas semanas la empresa gay
podrá finalizar el aseguramiento de la
obra
mientras tanto en parís cuando todas las
miradas están puestas en los tejados
ya está en marcha una obra de
restauración muy importante darles nueva
vida a las capillas que han resistido el
paso de los siglos
las partes bajas sufrieron un poco más
que encendió por la humedad
la subida capilar el agua que los
bomberos tuvieron que usar para apagar
el fuego tras este trabajo pedimos
limpiar y fue entonces cuando
descubrimos toda esta magnífica gama de
colores que datan de violet
viollet le duc el legendario arquitecto
francés que restauró el edificio en 1843
bajo el polvo secular y luego las
cenizas y el plomo provocados por el
fuego se escondían tesoros de un valor
incalculable obras maestras que cobran
vida gracias a marie paraná y su equipo
ahí se ve que hay colores que van con
los vitrales el azul es el mismo azul
del vitral el rojo es el mismo rojo del
vitral y del mismo modo en el capitel se
encuentra el mismo azul el mismo rojo
con verde hay un juego de colores por
todas partes al igual que el resto del
edificio estas capillas fueron
restauradas sobre la base de los
trabajos realizados en el siglo 19
nosotros como restauradores no cambiamos
nada no añadimos nada todos los colores
que se ven son los originales de viole
de duch las restauradoras tardaron más
de dos meses en devolver a estas
capillas de prueba su antiguo esplendor
esta es la base para las otras 22
capillas de la catedral en lo alto es
imposible no sentirse privilegiado
a menudo decimos que estamos entre el
cielo y la tierra y que somos como los
pintores cuando hicieron la decoración
estamos realmente en el mismo lugar al
mismo nivel y ese es muy agradable muy
muy agradable podemos ver las pinceladas
[Música]
los visitantes nunca antes vieron
colores tan vivos
y se supone que podrán admirar los a
partir de 2024 claro está hay que
cumplir con los plazos
la primera piedra de la catedral se
colocó en 1163 y desde entonces la
catedral siempre ha estado en
construcción
el general jon luego de la cndh es el
gran jefe de la obra actual crisis
sanitaria clown mal tiempo las
dificultades se acumularon a sus equipos
sólo les quedan tres años para restaurar
el monumento es un programa
extremadamente ambicioso seguimos
adelante con la meta de reabrir la
catedral para el culto en 2024 por
supuesto estará lejos de estar terminada
todavía habrá que realizar trabajos en
el exterior especialmente en las
fachadas exteriores de la catedral y
sobre todo queremos completar la fase de
aseguramiento que no estará terminada
hasta el verano
hoy empieza la última fase para
salvarnos quedan las siembras de café
que llegaron a parís
el momento es crítico a 30 metros de
altura basta un movimiento en falso para
que la siembra colisione con los
andamios o peor aún con el todavía
frágil edificio
[Música]
encontramos también que son bajo las
bóvedas el equipo lleva meses esperando
esta operación de rescate
[Música]
si eligiéramos la catedral colocamos
muletas y las piezas para sostenerlo
todo porque hay mucho desorden una
siembra pesa un promedio de 15 toneladas
así que cuando una de ellas es levantada
los obreros
aguantan la respiración
no es fácil siempre es una
responsabilidad nuestro equipo está
abajo así que siempre hay un poco de
riesgo un poco de viento nunca se sabe
todo va bien estamos muy contentos y
seguimos asegurando la obra de bojan
tras esta última fase el alivio es
palpable
en nuestro currículum pondremos la
experiencia de otra dama de hecho no nos
damos cuenta pero cuando vemos puestas
las piezas de la estructura y que todo
va bien nos sentimos muy contentos y muy
orgullosos orgullo una palabra en boca
de todos mientras la vieja notre damme
se cura las heridas todos estamos muy
orgullosos de trabajar en esta obra
orgullosos porque como lo hemos dicho
muchas veces es un monumento emblemático
de francia la catedral gótica por
excelencia y sentimos que todo el mundo
nos mira y nos observa somos conscientes
de lo que está en juego de las
dificultades hoy tenemos derecho a
equivocarnos y todos damos lo mejor para
que este proyecto se ha acabado y sea
bien acabado
[Música]
harán falta algunos años más de este
minucioso trabajo antes de que notre
damme pueda resurgir entre sus cenizas
mientras tanto la catedral de 850 años
se limpia las heridas
en el corazón de parís
llegamos al final de boleto de vuelta en
otra edad
recuerde que si quiere ver este y otros
contenidos en español puede visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta pronto